So once again we're just going to use the
distributive property in the same way as
we've done it many, many times before. The
difference this time and what may have
confused some people, is that our factor,
our little a up here. If you can see, is
actually two things multiplied together.
However that does not change the way that
we use the distributive property at all.
As always the -5y, the factor out in
front, is going to multiply each term
inside here, both the y And the z. So our
first term is going to be -5y * y, and our
second term is just going to be -5y * z.
Now again, I've just put an addition sign
between the two terms for simplicity right
now, so that I can determine the sign of
each term within the term itself, and then
change this to a - sign if I need to.
That's just a lot easier for me personally
to not get my signs mixed up. So now we
simplify within each term. And we end up
with -5y^2 - 5yz. So you can see that no
matter how many things are multiplied
together to create the factor that we have
out in front of our parentheses, they all
multiply each of the terms within the
parentheses.